cierra los ojos y trae a tu mente ese
momento ya ha vivido en lo que va de
este año
que sabes que se va a convertir en uno
de tus mejores recuerdos de toda la vida
por lo feliz que te hizo sentir
es más es de ese tipo de recuerdos que
hoy es solamente volverte a acordar de
él ya veo como te pinta nuevamente una
sonrisa en la cara
pueden abrir los ojos y hoy quiero
empezar haciendo un experimento social
con la ayuda de todos ustedes y las
tarjetas que encontraban esos en sus
asientos al volver del descanso y si
estás viendo esto desde tu casa toma los
objetos que tengas cerca uno va a
representar la tarjeta rosa y otra va a
representar la tarjeta amarilla los
objetos que puedas levantar
lo primero que yo quiero probar es que
todos podemos distinguir los colores
entonces vamos a hacer una primera
prueba levanten muy en alto a la tarjeta
amarilla las personas que disfrutan
mucho ver series
aunque la siguiente pregunta me gusta
porque siempre causa controversia pero
levanten muy en alto la tarjeta rosa las
personas que como yo creen que los
mejores tacos al pastor están en
guadalajara
ven esta es otra manera de preguntar
quiénes son foráneos y quiénes son
locales pero les doy la bienvenida a
todos por igual abre la mente en la
tarjeta amarilla muy en alto quienes se
encuentran viviendo actualmente su etapa
de estudiantes
cuál es ese momento que ya dijiste en tu
etapa de estudiantes que lo mismo sabes
que se va a convertir en un recuerdo
feliz para toda la vida traerlo a tu
mente y también si ya pasaron más años
desde que viviste tu etapa de
estudiantes no importa porque estoy
segura de que ahorita ya viene a tu
mente un muy buen recuerdo que viviste
cuando eras estudiante con eso recuerdo
en mente les quiero hacer la siguiente
pregunta y vamos a votar al mismo tiempo
dependiendo si ese recuerdo sucedió
dentro del contexto de una clase van a
levantar la tarjeta amarilla y si
sucedió fuera del contexto de una clase
van a levantar la tarjeta rosa en este
momento porfa
ok
esto es muy interesante porque yo le
estaba preguntando por momentos felices
de su etapa de estudiantes y muchos me
dicen que sucedieron fuera de una clase
bien para terminar este experimento
social vamos a hacer un reto de 20
segundos super rápido la última tarjeta
que haya seleccionado la vas a convertir
en pelota en bolita en una pelota
perfecta redonda enseñar a las personas
que están al lado de ti que si fuiste al
kinder y te enseñaron a hacer bolitas de
papel
y ese último recuerdo que vino a tu
mente ese momento feliz de tu etapa de
estudiante yo quiero que me digas esto
crees que alguien lo pensó a propósito
que alguien lo diseñó para que sucediera
tal y como sucedió o que realmente fue
un momento que pasó espontáneo y no pudo
tener la mente de nadie detrás si eso
recuerdo que estás pensando fue planeado
por alguien cuando yo de la señal esa
pelota perfecta que tienes la vas a
lanzar hacia el escenario y si fue un
momento completamente espontáneo lo vas
a lanzar a las filas de atrás y si estás
en tu casa si quieres no lances nada
solamente disfruta este momento 1 2 3
excelente
bueno yo hoy no estoy aquí para
contarles que soy una experticia
profesora o que ya muchísimos años de
experiencia me respaldan porque la
verdad es que ninguna de esas dos cosas
son ciertas
pero precisamente por mi ignorancia en
muchos temas de pedagogía y porque de
una u otra manera yo siempre me terminó
convirtiendo otra vez en alumna han
surgido enmiendas ganas tremendas de ser
diferente de no ser una profesora más
que da una clase más es como me dijo un
profesor que está por aquí es que no se
necesita hacer para hacer no se necesita
hacer la profesora con más años de
experiencia para hacer una materia
interesante o no se necesita hacer la
profesora que tenga en la pared la mayor
cantidad de títulos colgados para hacer
sesiones que realmente emocionen y
enganchen a nuestros estudiantes
lo que definitivamente no podemos ser es
profesores básicos profesoras básicas es
más yo estoy convencida de que como
profesores tenemos el poder de
transformar cada una de nuestras
sesiones en momentos mágicos que viven
nuestros alumnos
en otras industrias ya se toma muy en
serio el tema de diseño de experiencias
y estoy segura de que como usuarios lo
agradecemos bastante entonces de unos
semestres hacia acá yo me he puesto a
ver qué dice la teoría de diseño de
experiencias y cómo lo puedo conectar
con lo que sucede a lo largo de una
clase y ha encontrado cuestiones
bastante interesantes que ahora está uso
cuando planeo mis clases el primer
concepto que me gusta muchísimo es el
concepto de las emociones y sobre todo
las emociones positivas porque miren las
emociones se pueden medir las emociones
se pueden predecir y las podemos
predecir cuando ya conocemos a nuestro
grupo de usuarios a nuestro público a
nuestros estudiantes y sabemos cómo van
a reaccionar ante uno u otro estímulo
que tengamos previamente planeado
entonces cuando yo veo esto de las
emociones y pienso como quisiera que
viajen a lo largo de una clase en lugar
de pensar en que van a ser una línea
recta
plana monótona aburrida
a mí me gusta pensar que son como una
montaña rusa de emociones una montaña
rusa pues que a veces y las emociones
serán más intensas a veces serán más
neutrales
y en que más tengo que pensar bueno pues
que mi clase no es un evento aislado el
mundo no empieza y se termina en mi
clase sino que mis estudiantes vendrán
de alguna experiencia previa
puede ser que yo tenga la buenísima
suerte de que vengan de una experiencia
que me los deja con entusiasmo con
felicidad con motivación
o puedo tener la malísima suerte que ya
he tenido también de que vengan de una
experiencia previa que nos deja con
frustración con estrés con dudas
existenciales
pero de algún lado vendrán y qué bueno
sería que yo sepa de dónde vienen para
que entonces lo primero que yo diseñé
sea la mejor bienvenida del mundo para
cada una de mis sesiones y no importa de
dónde vengan me aseguro de que al menos
equilibramos las emociones a la parte
positiva y empezamos todos en el mismo
nivel la nueva experiencia de las clases
entonces me han preguntado en el que
tienen tus clases para que tus alumnos
no pierdan las ganas de ir después de la
tercera clase ok
en este tiempo donde tienen la
posibilidad de ir a la universidad o
quedarse en su casa de la transmisión
las sillas que yo tengo disponibles en
mi salón de clases estén siempre siempre
llenas
no hay unas recetas mágicas como tal
pero si les tengo que contar que semana
tras semana yo tengo que hacer uso de
absolutamente todas todas todas toda la
micra tividad para no volverme
predecible
y tampoco todo es color de rosa ni todo
es tan bonito como se oye ni tan lindo
como lo hago ver en redes sociales
porque quién va a compartir tragedias en
redes sociales
pero también me frustrado también me han
salido mal las cosas también me enojado
por ejemplo el año pasado cuando todavía
transmitíamos las clases desde nuestras
casas por la pandemia había días en que
estar más preocupada por los ruidos de
la calle
los pasado el repartidor del gas los
perros ladraban a las moscas a mi vecina
hermosa dejaban salir a jugar siempre a
la hora de mi clase y parecía que le
decían que se pusiera bajo de mi ventana
pero desde aquí de mando saludos a los
papás de mi vecina y está la luz y por
si no se están viendo
pero de todas maneras no por eso podemos
bajar los brazos o perder las ganas de
exprimir toda nuestra creatividad en
cada una de nuestras sesiones
es como si cada clase fuera como una
caja
una caja que pues a simple vista siempre
es la misma siempre es lisa siempre es
del mismo color pero que estén nosotros
generar una curiosidad de nuestros
estudiantes porque el contenido de la
caja puede ser diferente en cada sesión
así les voy a contar de manera muy
rápida tres ejemplos que han pasado en
mis clases de ingenierías con
universitarios el primero la diferencia
que hace solamente decir ay hola
bienvenidos es una nueva semana entonces
tengo tres temas preparados
apunten primer tema el primer tema es ay
por dios qué aburrido que diferente es
decirles es una nueva semana y gracias
por estar aquí porque al final de esta
semana habrás creado un nuevo proyecto
que puede sobresalir en tu portafolio
profesional va a brillar porque ese
proyecto va a demostrar que tú ya
dominas para el tema y está el tema y
está el tema y son los temas que vamos a
ver en la semana
y entonces el interés por esos temas es
diferente porque ya no están pensando en
la clase de hoy sino que están pensando
en cómo quieren que se vea ese proyecto
y hasta las puertas que ese proyecto les
pueda abrir si queda bien hecho el
siguiente me gusta mucho y le mando un
saludo a todos los que aparecen en estas
fotos cuando les dijimos a los alumnos
bueno siguiente proyecto vamos a hacer
un reto vamos a diseñar un medio de
transporte acuático y que pueda flotar y
gerona sí
además lo vamos a ir a probar a un lago
real nos vamos a ir al lago de chapala y
dijeron guau un viaje incluido con este
proyecto
además vamos a ver que el que cada
proyecto pueda trasladar a un integrante
por equipo y ahí ya les cambiaron las
caras hay que hay personas que vivieron
eso
y también vamos a ver quién es el equipo
primero en cruzar la meta y regresar con
vida básicamente y sin perder la
dignidad
no bueno ni les cuento la emoción que se
vivía en el salón de clases las semanas
previas a ese proyecto porque claro
imagínense iban en primer semestre que
reputaciones iba a quedar para el resto
de la carrera si su proyecto no salía
bien y si un día no en frente de toda la
generación bueno siguiente ejemplo
cuando les dije saben que a este grupo
yo ya lo voy conociendo y me doy cuenta
de que tienen todo el potencial para que
el proyecto que estamos haciendo en este
semestre pues no se quede nada más aquí
en sus cuadernos en sus computadoras
sino que lo llevemos a alguna plataforma
internacional pero se animan a que les
subamos el nivel de la clase e incluso
trabajamos un poco extra por esto y unos
meses después yo era la profesora más
orgullosa de ver a mis estudiantes
exponiendo el resultado de sus proyectos
en la plataforma de un importante
congreso internacional
en el libro que se llama el poder de los
momentos de chip y danger nos dicen como
ya está comprobado que cuando vivimos
una experiencia y pasan los años
realmente son no nos vamos a acordar de
dos tipos de momentos los momentos de
máxima emoción y los momentos de cierre
esa última experiencia de esa última
interacción en otras palabras nos están
diciendo que no vale la pena
concentrarnos en diseñar absolutamente
cada segundo y cada minuto de la
experiencia sino que entendamos cuáles
son los momentos más importantes y donde
queremos impactar más y en eso nos
enfoquemos
y estarás pensando bueno sí muy
interesante pero yo no me dedico a dar
clases entonces a mí de qué me sirve
todo esto
la buena noticia es que si tú trabajas
con personas en tu vida diaria
interactúas con personas si te interesa
hacerles vivir una mejor experiencia que
te pongan atención o que después de
algunos años recuerden ese mensaje que
les quieres transmitir
puedes aplicar al menos uno de los
siguientes tres consejos que voy a dar
el primero
involucrar los sentidos entonces utiliza
colores vivos para que llame su atención
y se acuerden de ti cuando ya se acabó
la plática
utiliza la música cuando les doy la
bienvenida a una nueva experiencia o qué
tal ese olor que te relaja cuando vas
llegando un spa y se te olvida de dónde
vienes y dónde estabas antes
el número 2
involucra la sensación de competencia
por supuesto que nosotros queríamos que
los alumnos se investigarán sobre formas
materiales un poquito de física como no
morir en el lago de chapala como flotar
pero ellos lo querían hacer porque
precisamente querían ser los primeros en
cruzar la meta y porque su reputación
estaba está en juego recuerden número 3
rompe el guión
estudia a tu público entiende lo que
esperan de una típica experiencia y de
repente ofrecerles algo diferente
qué típico ya es contestar una encuesta
y votar abriendo un link en tu celular
por medio un código qr y quien dijo que
no podemos hacer una votación a partir
de pelotas de papel en medio de una
texto acá hay una pelota de papel
sabes cómo lograron en el hospital
pediátrico de pittsburgh pasar de un 80%
de pacientes que necesitaban algún tipo
de sedante para animarme a subir a la
máquina de resonancia magnética como
pensaron de esto a una niña que cuando
ya se baja de su turno en la resonancia
magnética le da la vuelta llega
corriendo con su papel y sé por favor no
puedo volver a subir el mapa como tú no
sabes cuánto cuesta cada que te subes
verdad como pasaron de esto a esto un
equipo de diseño liderado por duckwitz
entendió que los niños pasaban una
experiencia no muy placentera a lo largo
de toda su estancia en el hospital y
convirtió en los cuartos de resonancia
magnética en entornos de aventura
entonces a un niño le puede tocar un
barco le puede tocar una nave espacial
le puede tocar ser el capitán de un
submarino y la experiencia cambia
completamente
involucra los sentidos se involucra la
sensación de competencia y rompe el
guión yo estoy segura de que ahorita que
te estás imaginando cómo puedes hacer
diferente tu siguiente junta de trabajo
tu siguiente reunión de equipo la
siguiente clase que tienes que diseñar
te invito a probar cómo es convertirte
en creador o creadora de experiencias
como el punto de partida ya no es esa
lista de temas aburridas que tienes que
cubrir sino que el punto de partida son
las emociones que buscas propiciar en
las personas que van a estar contigo
para que recuerden el mensaje que les
quieres transmitir y claro que se cubran
esos temas que querías cubrir
[Aplausos]